what do you think is the timeline to
solve the problem of autonomous driving
this still in part an open question
yeah I think the tough thing with
timelines of self-driving obviously is
that no one has created self-driving
yeah so it's not like what do you think
is a timeline to build this bridge well
we've built million Bridges before
here's how long that takes it's you know
it's uh no one has built autonomy it's
not obvious uh some parts turn out to be
much easier than others so it's really
hard to forecast you do your best based
on trend lines and so on and based on
intuition but that's why fundamentally
is just really hard to forecast this no
one has to even still like being inside
of it is hard to uh to do yes some
things turn out to be much harder and
some things turn out to be much easier
do you try to avoid making forecasts
because like Elon doesn't avoid them
right and heads of car companies in the
past have not avoided it either uh Ford
and other places have made predictions
that we're going to solve at level four
driving by 2020 2021 whatever and now
they're all kind of Backtrack on that
prediction
IU as a
as an AI person
do you free yourself privately make
predictions or do they get in the way of
like your actual ability to think about
a thing
yeah I would say like what's easy to say
is that this problem is tractable and
that's an easy prediction to make
extractable it's going to work yes it's
just really hard some things turn out to
be harder than some things turn out to
be easier uh so uh but it definitely
feels tractable and it feels like at
least the team at Tesla which is what I
saw internally is definitely on track to
that how do you form
a uh strong representation that allows
you to make a prediction about
tractability so like you're the leader
of a lot a lot of humans
you have to kind of say this is actually
possible
like how do you build up that intuition
it doesn't have to be even driving it
could be other tasks it could be um
what difficult tasks did you work on in
your life I mean classification
achieving certain just an image that
certain level of superhuman level
performance yeah expert intuition
it's just intuition it's belief
so just like thinking about it long
enough like studying looking at sample
data like you said driving
uh my intuition has really flawed on
this like I don't have a good intuition
about tractability it could be either it
could be anything it could be solvable
like uh you know the driving task could
could be simplified into something quite
trivial like uh the solution to the
problem would be quite trivial and at
scale more and more cars driving
perfectly
might make the problem much easier Yeah
the more cars you have driving like
people learn how to drive correctly not
correctly but in a way that's more
optimal for a heterogeneous system of
autonomous and semi-autonomous and
manually driven cars that could change
stuff then again also I've spent a
ridiculous number of hours just staring
at pedestrians crossing streets thinking
about humans and it feels like the way
we use our eye contact
it sends really strong signals and
there's certain quirks and edge cases of
behavior and of course a lot of the
fatalities that happen have to do with
drunk driving and
um both on The Pedestrian side and the
driver's side so there's that problem of
driving at night and all that kind of
yeah so I wonder you know it's like the
space
of possible solution to autonomous
driving includes so many human factor
issues
that it's almost impossible to predict
there could be super clean nice
Solutions yeah I would say definitely
like to use a game analogy there's some
fog of War but you definitely also see
the frontier of improvement and you can
measure historically how much you've
made progress and I think for example at
least what I've seen in uh roughly five
years at Tesla when I joined it barely
kept laying on the highway I think going
up from Palo Alto to SF was like three
or four interventions anytime the road
would do anything geometrically or turn
too much it would just like not work and
so going from that to like a pretty
competent system in five years and
seeing what happens also under the hood
and what the scale of which the team is
operating now with respect to data and
compute and everything else uh is just a
massive progress
so this is uh you're climbing a mountain
and yes fog but you're making a lot of
progress fog you're making progress and
you see what the next directions are and
you're looking at some of the remaining
challenges and they're not like uh
they're not perturbing you and they're
not changing your philosophy and you're
not contorting yourself you're like
actually these are the things that we
still need to do yeah the fundamental
components of solving the problems seem
to be there for the data engine to the
compute to the the computer on the car
to the compute for the training all that
kind of stuff